I think the turning point was when we
got a turnover and then we didn't
execute on offense and I got the ball
right back and drove it 87 yards or how
far was as an offense we have two in the
game right there we didn't George kiddo
summing it up after the game and that
was the moment in the fourth quarter
when the second Patrick mahomes
interception gave the 49ers the ball
with 1157 to play and a ten point lead
and they had the ball and the drive
started off in spectacular fashion as we
discussed in the last segment two plays
18 yards here we go this one's over at
Chris when an interception that was like
this one's over it's over
I most people even the most ardent
Chiefs fan had to look at that and say
it's over and then it wasn't
and we talked earlier about two three
jet chip wasp that play that popped it
and really before that play before that
44 yard game the long throw from Patrick
my Hamza Tyreke Hill before that it just
felt like the Chiefs were destined to
lose yeah and it all changed the vibe
changed in that one moment and you
talked about that Seattle defense and
how how you can beat that that cover
three zone and they set them up that's
how Peter peanuts they did all morning
in America right same play in the first
half they ran it again in the second
half reminds me that Brandon cooks non
touchdown last year remember that yeah
they ran it again in the second half and
it popped wide open but Jared Goff saw
him too late Patrick mahomes saw Tyree
kill just in time got the ball there
Jimmy Ward didn't get over in time after
Hill unexpectedly broke to the outside
and that changed everything
yeah well there you know it like we've
talked about like we talked about in the
first hour greatest show on turf I hear
you know they're like the Golden State
Warriors I get it cuz once they see the
ball go through the hoop it's just like
oh here we go guys are wide open
mahomes it doesn't matter if anybody's
open or not they all look wide open he
just starts throwing rifles all over the
field and that that play I'm third and
15 I did thinking you know of course
gave them confidence and jump-started
the rally but then for the defense to
make the big stop as we talked about a
little bit earlier where Chris Jones
comes with up with the big bad it batted
pass on second and five and then right
back into their hands again mahomes and
company with the hot hand and it took
what two plays and the great throat of
Sammy walkins down the sideline and you
just went whoa this is what we've seen
all playoffs here we go they're on fire
it took all day and then in the Super
Bowl but they finally got it and they
got it to the point where the 49ers
their defense was on the field a good
amount they're not used to playing that
way because Andy Reid was actually
patient with running the football and
pretty patient with the short passing
game and the pass rush of the 49ers was
exhausted too he wore them out I didn't
think he could wear this defense out he
did it he did it again and that's where
he's just he's off the charts good it's
just I've never seen anything like it
he's got a chance to be the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen his talent
his composure all of it just is through
the roof and that's why the Chiefs are
Super Bowl champs because I just don't
know if there's another quarterback in
football that could have done what
Patrick mahomes did yesterday that was
hard work they didn't pipe bad defense
it's just mahomes made plays escape
sacks I mean made little four and five
yard completions where I'm gonna go ooh
I mean just great job adjusting your arm
angle or breaking an arm tackle instead
of getting sack to make the drive keep
going a lot like this play right here
oh yeah that's only gymnic Bosa on your
back grabbing you yeah I just throw a
jump hook in there too Travis Kelce oh
now the you know the pockets good uh-oh
I got a good beat on the line of
scrimmage with Sammy Watkins BAM right
on the money I mean he's just amazing
and it's a lot a lot of fun to watch hey
one of the examples we used last week
the idea that the San Francisco
defensive line was gonna feel like rocky
and rocky to chasing the chicken before
he got in the shape that's what they
felt like they couldn't track him down
that was one of the keys of the game if
they could get to remember we say he
never stands still he's always moving
you can't get a bead on can't get that a
heat lock on the on the jet and Top Gun
before you released the missile they
couldn't do it brah I got to him a
couple times but not consistently like
they have to every quarterback they've
beaten this year no that's it Mike and
you know I'm glad you brought this up
because this is another thing you talked
about the last two weeks or the last two
games with San Francisco and you really
pounded the table with Aaron Rodgers
and you were right man you were right
you were right yesterday they moved him
a lot that is something you know we're
gonna we can't forget this a little bit
we're gonna lose this in the context of
the game and all the big plays but Andy
Reid and some of the game plan design
plays to get on the edge or just give
misdirection you know the fourth and one
plays the the third in one plays none of
it was like oh we're just gonna run
right at you right when run up the
middle because he wasn't like he went
like screw that
have you seen their D line they have to
tree trunks in the middle D Ford and
Nick Bose on the edge why would we run
at them let's fake running at them and
then get on the edge and let my home's
run you know option pitches or keep the
ball for a touchdown he used their
aggressiveness against them by moving
mahomes and ultimately wore them out and
kept the clock running and really did a
lot of the things the 49ers have done to
people all year long and kind of threw
it back in their face and played the
same style of football and that's where
Andy read all the years we talk about
being an offensive genius BAM Andy Reid
good for you you came through was
unbelievable and it's because of his
game planning really that got them off
to a good start and got their team at
least a little cushion early on to where
yeah it left them in a spot to where
they could come back later on yeah and
even then we needed that explosion that
we have seen from Chiefs from time to
time within the context of one quarter
usually it's like the second quarter
they if we had yet to see them wake up
so dramatically yeah that's the game on
the line like it was you know the they
were down 24 nothing in the second
quarter against the Texans and they led
by halftime they were down 10 points
twice in the second quarter of the game
against the Titans and they led by
halftime this time around it just it had
a different vibe we all fell for it we
were all set up what we didn't see it
coming we know what they're capable of
but we did not think they'd be able to
do it and I don't know what happened to
the 49ers psychologically whether
whether they maybe just slid their foot
off the gas just a little bit what you
can't do against the Chiefs but or maybe
didn't matter maybe was gonna happen no
matter what the 49ers did but it is
amazing to see how that that offense can
just explode at a moment's notice which
means they are in every game Kris no
matter how far behind they are I've out
a 10-point lead for the 49ers second
half no way in hell Chiefs are gonna
overcome it and they made it look easy
well it's the greatest quarterback in
the game with a really good pass
protecting Oh line
that pass protected just good enough to
not let the 49ers great D line ruin the
game and then I heard Troy Aikman say it
last night I know you and I have said
this 50 times during the season when the
Chiefs have Kelsey Tyree kill and Sammy
Watkins all healthy it's just hard to
match up and cover all three of them
especially with that guy pulling the
trigger in the backend number 15 it's
just hard it's just there it's almost
like you know what do I want a force of
nature where you just go yeah it's been
good and we're slowing them down
but man it only takes one of these guys
to make a player too and it just sets
them on fire and that's where I just
don't remember ever seeing an offense
you know an NFL football really play
like it is like a basketball team in a
lot of ways where they can make a 15 a
20 point run in a game and you just go
how why they they weren't even really
dominating this game or controlling the
football game and then all of a sudden
they swing the the momentum their
direction and they're like a different
team and you go well this is the best
team in football that they're
unstoppable and when they do that they
are and that's why they won the Super
Bowl
you asked during the break what the
breakdown was yeah these fans of riding
on his fans and and and there were at
least 75% Chiefs fans sounds like it
down from the press box at the Chiefs
endzone the yellow end zone with the
Chiefs logo and name there that's where
it felt like there was the biggest
cluster like where it got the loudest
but but all the action of the game was
at the other end like all the scoring it
seemed like was it the far end of the
field it never really got to the point
where the Chiefs could take advantage of
that noise but the as the game was
moving toward a conclusion and the 49ers
had the ball it started on their own 15
Richie James junior brought the ball out
got tackled at the 15 on the kick return
the 49ers moved 36 yards and they had a
1st and 10 on the Kansas City 49 and I'm
texting my son because they're sitting
right below it's like here we're gonna
see we may see the 49ers win this thing
right in front of us and Chris third and
10 now I haven't seen a replay of it
because so much has been happening and
the game you know the Chiefs get the
ball back
oh yeah but but look 3rd and 10 Emmanuel
Sanders was open yeah right right
Emmanuel Sanders is open and this isn't
quite as glaring as Jared Goff missing
Brandon cooks last year but the best
quarterbacks on the planet make that
throw that's a championship moment throw
can you imagine how we would be talking
about Jimmy Garoppolo today if he
delivered in that spot with Emmanuel
Sanders open open enough not wide open
up but open enough that and he put a
little too much on it that that's a 2nd
quarter overthrow where you don't want
to take a chance of an interception
right with the Super Bowl on the line
you got to take a little bit off of that
and run the risk that maybe it gets
picked off well it's something we don't
see from them a lot that's not one of
their bread and butters really the deep
pass right I mean think about the throws
we saw yesterday from Jimmy Garoppolo
you know as I've said a lot of times on
the show it's over the middle it's over
the middle it's over the middle here it
is yes there it is I mean yes Patrick
mahomes is gonna hit that that doesn't
you know listen I don't know what else
to say yes this is not G this is Jimmy
Garoppolo is really good but he's not a
superstar and then throwing the deep
ball and this like formula has not been
one of the go-to things for the 49ers
all year long anyways but it came down
to finally Kansas City got the game in -
oh and we heard some of their players
comment about this this past week
especially Frank Clark we're gonna try
to make Jimmy Garoppolo beat us it took
them almost a whole game to finally get
them to pull have to play that style of
football but they finally got it
they're within the last two and a half
drives of the game and yes Garoppolo and
the drop back pass game could not win it
for the San Francisco 49ers and you're
right that was a big moment hey he hits
that right let me ask ores but there was
gonna be a minute 40 left with mahomes
having the ball so that doesn't mean
they were gonna win the game either I've
never never gonna say that with moms
let me ask because I tell you as that
play was done forwarding and I said oh
and and and I'm not saying there are ten
quarterbacks that can make that throw
there's maybe three or four but Jimmy
G's not one of them and Chris you know I
got to take a break here but something
to ponder and yeah I kind of saw this
coming at some point in the postseason I
know question was gonna come up and if
I'm a 49ers fan I know how important is
you're going I'm saying we can upgrade
at quarterback I'm saying this guys are
a weak link am I wrong no I'm not saying
you know I don't know I don't agree with
that are we going to commercial or not
cuz this is a deep conversation we got
to get back into this where are we gonna
go put a pin in that okay let's put a
pin in that one
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports